ابدا معك منما ذكره الزميل وائل في افادته
السابقه عن تصعيد واضح في وتيره القصف
الجوي في وسط وجنوب قطاع غزه بعد ما كان
تراجع لصالح المسيرات والقصف المدفعي كيف
يمكن ان نفهم
ذلك فيدا هي عمليه تحضير للعمليات
العسكريه القادمه على سبيل المثال كان في
جنوب القطاع اربعه الويه
تقاتل بالاضافه الى لوائين للحمايه
واللوجستيه البارحه اضيف اليهم لواء وكان
هناك عمليه تسريع عمليه القصف الجوي هي
عمليه توفير الجهد العسكري والتقليل من
الخسائر ولكن الملاحظ فدا ان هناك اغلب
العمليات التي تحصل جنوب القطاع شرق هان
يونس على الحدود مع اسرائيل في عبسان في
خزاعه وكانه اليوم هناك محاوله لتحديد
منطقه عازله كما تحدث عنها نتنياهو في
مقاله بالول ستريت جورنال فاذا هذه مرحله
قد تنضم اليها في البريج مثلا ايضا هي
قريبه الى الحدود من بين القطاع واسرائيل
وكانه نرى ان هناك نفقا او هناك منطقه
معينه بعمق 2 كم تقريبا بين الشمال
والجنوب تمتد على طول كل القطاع من الجهه
الشرقيه ال المنطقه الامنه وهذا احدى يعني
احدى الافكار واحدى المؤشرات طيب عندما
يقول وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف جالنت ان
مهمه اسرائيل تكمن في تفكيك حماس حتى لا
تكون لها قدره عسكريه بعد 3 يوما لم يتحقق
شيء من اهداف هذه العمليه ما مدى واقعيه
ما يطرحه في ظل حجم الخسائر التي تمنى بها
اسرائيل داخل
القطاع
ايضا فدا عندما يتحدث البعد السياسي شيء
يجب ان ننظر الى الامكانيات والقدره على
التنفيذ يعني حماس حضرت ارضيه المعركه على
ثلاث مستويات فدا المستوى الاول يبعد عن
السياج الشهير الذكي والذي تم خرقه في 7
اكتوبر بعمق 2 م داخل القطاع حضرتها الغام
تفجيرات اماكن جاهزه ل
الكمائن البعد الثاني او المستوى الثاني
للدفاع هو على تخوم المدن اما المستوى
الثالث وهو داخل المدن وداخل الانفاق ان
كانت داخل القطاع او التي تمتد الى الداخل
الاسرائيلي اليوم القتال يحصل في هذه
الثلاث مستويات الاساسيه وهذا امر صعب بعد
82 او 83 يوم على القتال خسائر كبيره ولا
قدره على قياس النجاح عميد الياس عند
عندما يقول رئيس هيئه الاركان الاسرائيلي
مقتل الجنود الثلاثه بغزه حادث خطير وله
عواقب وخيمه للغايه ما طبيعه هذه العواقب
التي يمكن ان تترتب على حادث مماثل من
الناحيه
العسكريه داخل
الجيش هذه ليست هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي يحصل فيها ما يسمى بنيران صديقه هذا
الامر يدل على الهاجس
او الصدمه التي يقاتل فيها على مسرح الحرب
الذي لا يعرفه يعني في هكذا نوع من القتال
فذا عندما يتقدم الجندي يتقدم الى المجهول
يعني الجبهه هي امامه يمينه يساره ورائه
ومن فوق وحتى من تحت الانفاق وهذا امر
يؤدي الى خلل بالمعنويات للعسكر من هنا
عدم القدره على التفريق بين مقاتلي
المقاومه او حتى الجنود الاسرائيليين
والذين تكلموا بالعبريه وحتى وضعوا هذا
الشعار على البنايه انقذونا